how do you say this word fun fact it's
the State Nut of Alabama Arkansas
California and Texas but is it pean peon
pean or even pan I don't know anyone who
says that last one maybe you say it
differently in different contexts butter
pean ice cream pecan pie well you're
free to say what you want but we get the
name for the nut which is native to
North America from the people who are
native to North America specifically
from those who speak El gangin languages
of which there are around 30 in kapoo
the word for n is pakana in manaman it's
pan in OJ Moen Bagan in patami Bagan or
pan and in Miami Illinois pakani and
while people in the US have all sorts of
different pronunciations for those same
five letters it seems like the closer
you are to the area where the trees
natively grow the more likely you are to
have the source pronunciation pean so
the next time you're cracking nuts or
sitting down to a nice slice of pie you
might take a second to think about where
your words came from